معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي العقيد حاتم اذا تابعت اهم
التطورات في الساعات الماضيه التركيز و
يعني اشرس العمليه تتم في خان يونس وكذلك
في مخيمات في وسط القطاع ماذا عن اهم ما
رصدته في الساعات الماضيه عن
العمليات نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره نعم لا شك بانه خلال الساعه
الماضيه او ال 24 ساعه الماضيه حاول العدو
ان يطور من هجومه باتجاه خان يونس وباتجاه
القاطع الاوسط وكانت الليله الماضيه هي
ليله قاسيه على القاطع الاوسط بشكل كبير
نتيجه القصف الذي لم يتوقف من قبل
الطائرات ومن قبل المدفعيه والطائرات
المسيره وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن عمليه
عسكريه الان جهدها الرئيسي في القاطع
الاوسط والجهد الاخر في خان يونس باضافه
الى جهد ثانوي لازال متواجد في القطاع
الشمالي لذلك هو يحاول التوغل الان الى
عمق منطقه خان يونس وكان هناك قصف في ليله
امس على حي الامل الذي يعتبر هذا الحي هو
مركز خان يونس بالنسبه للقطاع الجنوبي
ويحاول التوغل والتقدم في اتجاهات مختلفه
بحثا عن الانفاق وبحثا عن مراكز القياده
والسيطره كما يقول وبحثا عن مخازن الاسلحه
والاعتداء التي تتواجد في هذه المنطقه
ولكن عندما يتكلم ويقول بانه تم استهداف
منذ يوم امس ما يقارب 1000 هدف اقول 100
هدف اذا نحن نتكلم عن اهداف يعني لازالت
كثيره بالنسبه للعدو لم يتم استهدافها اذا
ماذا كان يفعل خلال ثلاثه اشهر الماضيه
انا اعتقد بان هذا القصف وهذا التدبير
الذي طال جميع مناطق غزه كان يجب ان لا ت
لا توجد هناك اهداف يقوم بقصفها الان ولكن
عندما يقول وجدت هناك 100 هدف اذا هو يقول
بان هناك لازالت قدرات عسكريه متواجده ولا
زالت هناك اهداف في داخل هذه المدينه وهذا
يوضع علامه استفهام كبيره جدا على اداء
القوات الصهيونيه في هذه المنطقه سواء
كانت في الشمال او في الوسط او في الجنوب
هو يحاول الان هو بالامس فصل القطاع
الاوسط فصل المنطقه الشرقيه على المنطقه
الغربيه يعني منطقه النصيرات ومنطقه
الزوايده فصلها عن طريق عن المغازي وعن
البريج ويحاول ان يتقدم في هذه المنطقه
ويعزل هذه المناطق واحده عن الاخرى لكي
يتمكن من السيطره عليها وهذه الع عمليات
تقوم بها الفرقه 36 اما في الجنوب فهو
يتقدم بمحورين المحور الشمالي والمحور
الشرقي وك المحورين تقريبا التقدم بسيط
جدا لا يكاد نقول بانه هناك تطور كبير جدا
في مساله التوغل ولكن هناك قصف كبير جدا
يطال الكثير من الاحياء وهناك ايضا مفارز
تعويق من قبل فصائل المقاومه تحاول منع
القطعات المتقدمه من الوصول الى اهدافها
خلال هذه
العمليه شكرا لك من اسطنبول الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم
الفلاحي